welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for this unique opportunity
to directly address awardees of the
research on humans division of the brain
initiative it's my pleasure to introduce
our panel of experts will be available
to answer questions during this live Q&A
our experts are dr. Elizabeth Buffalo
dr. Healy root is Howser and dr. Robert
bond will be sitting in for dr. Jennifer
colander for more information about our
awardees please refer to the speaker
biographies in the center of your screen
my name is dr. rush and I caution you
that would be the moderator for today's
Q&A session la groots is delighted to
bring you this incredible opportunity we
would also like to extend our special
thanks to the brain initiative program
directors in particular dr. James nag
for their efforts in organizing today's
session this session is interactive so
please submit your questions by clicking
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box as time
allows for so let's get started our
first question is for dr. Buffalo
commonalities in the structure of
stimuli promote our learning under what
circumstances or how can our mental
schema be upended how is it what are the
powerful triggering variables Thanks so
this is a really interesting question
and something that we're hoping to
address as part of our research into the
u-19 grant as I was talking about in my
presentation
it's these commonalities and the
structure across trials or across
stimulus modality that we think leads to
the formation of a schema which may
support rapid formation of new memories
and we've seen based on data has been
collected in previous studies in rodents
that the hippocampus can support this
kind of schema development and that we
know that the the response of
hippocampal neurons stays constant
through subtle changes in the context or
the trial on structure
but these responses can change
dramatically as soon as the animal
attends to something novel in the
environment that leads to a different
kind of behavioral response and so we
think that really when the mental schema
is upended that happens due to really
strong changes in the relationship
between what the organism is doing and
kind of the the response or reward
outcome so the scale with familiarity
how would that speak to what we just
heard as far as being able to up and
where you've got these neurons that are
context dependent responsive versus
familiarity dependent responsive so how
would that balance sort of play into
this that's my questions all right
yes I think thanks for that question so
first of all thanks for having me this
is a very unique opportunity it's the
first time I'm we can talk from my
office so bear with me I used to that
user that that question fits very
perfectly so in fact what we have found
is that that there are some neurons as
you mentioned which care about memory
strength meaning they care about how
familiar something is and they the more
they fire the more familiar it is but we
also described another group of neurons
which only care about whether you have
seen a stimulus never before we call
those novelty neurons and presumably
those novelty neurons would be if I
understand I understand Beth's argument
correctly would be what triggers
instantiation of a new schema and what's
really interesting about these novelty
neurons is that they really only fire in
terms of increasing the firing rate the
very first time you see something the
second time they don't react anymore so
that they would be ideally suited to
trigger this initiation of a new schema
I would think we've seen those kinds of
cell
across different modalities not just in
the visual system as well we have a
question for dr. Condor at dr. bond the
study and your findings have been quite
interesting to learn about if the study
continues what are some of the next
hypotheses and tests you are considering
to further advance the knowledge in the
space
yeah LIGO everybody's comment so far
about it and thanks for being involved
thanks for this opportunity and it's a
it's certainly unique not have to fly
somewhere and sit around in a hotel to
do this quite nice and I'll do my best
to fill in for Jen on this she's on
family vacation this week so I work with
her closely on these projects so I guess
I'll do my best so the question about
wouldn't we see going on in the future
first of all we really do want to keep
doing this sort of work it's you know
more and more labs are starting to do
this and which is fantastic yeah so the
project were working on really is
focused on trying to restore dexterous
motion and people who have lost it
because of injury or disease and so we
work with people with degenerative
disorders or spinal cord injury who
can't move their arms anymore
they're really what we want to be able
to do is extract information from the
brain to allow them to control a robot
or some device a computer whatever they
choose as well as be able to put
information back into the brain through
stimulation of sensory somehow sensory
regions of the brain so that they can
perceive sensations so you can imagine
being paralyzed reaching out with a
robot arm to pick something up and then
feeling it as you contact as you grasp
the as you grasp
whatever it is you want to and then
bring it back to manipulate it so those
are the sorts of experiments that are
going on routinely in our lab right now
and the questions thinking into the
future that we're particularly motivated
by are ones that lead to better use and
better ability to control these devices
so the things that we can't do very well
right now I would say are you know
dexterous hand motions and so while we
can
pick up a water bottle pick up large
objects picking up fine instruments pens
coins things like that they're difficult
for us and we think that through the
integration of sensory feedback into the
control will improve that but you know
those are learning how to extract
information to be able to do dexterous
hand control as well as ways to be able
to integrate sensory information back
into that are the sorts of tasks that
we're working on thinking about in the
future thank you we have another
question for you dr. Burgess Houser your
recordings are from epilepsy patients
can't memory be affected as part of
morbidity
how would you normalize for that yes
thanks yeah absolutely can so in fact
that's one of the main reasons we do
this research is that that we would like
to figure out how we can address this
comorbidity by developing new treatments
for memory disorders so epilepsy most
definitely affects fact ability to
memorize so that the way we deal with
this is that we've carefully
characterized our patients in terms of
their ability on standardized tests and
and we see whether their mechanisms we
describe are affected by these scores
and by and large they are not and we
also while while epilepsy on average
does affect memory for many people in
fact it does not so they have normal
scores so we can look at that subset
alone and compare it with the state
where it is affected and one finds by
and large the same mechanisms however
that they are they're interesting ways
that that are revealed by doing this by
which epilepsy does affect memory and
one of the things that we have described
and that we have found is that these
novelty neurons that I talked about
before they still exist so if you
compare a novelty neuron in the
hemisphere which was later respected
versus the hemisphere which was not
resected
which was healthy in clothes versus not
you find that the novelty neurons in the
later respected hemisphere they still
exist but they did their response
strength is is weakened so that's a
potential way that you can explain why
they have a memory deficit in that their
novelty detection mechanism is is
impaired in that sense um I saw a
related question to that here for you
somewhere up here would you say that
confidence increases memory retrieval or
is that it yes would you say that
confidence increases memory retrieval or
capacity or is it just that these
familiarity and novel neurons that scale
with confidence or simply responses to
familiarity and then that I think it
speaks into when you have the epilepsy
patients I'm not sure if you recorded of
how close to an event when they have an
aura or not and how that might also
affect it yes yeah those are two very
interesting questions so the first
question that we think that confidence
that the sense of confidence is a direct
correlate of memory strength so that
means and and that correlate efemer
saying is relative to them to the
memories things that that person has so
if a person has high confidence in a
particular trial they would have high
memory strength relative to whatever
memory strength they are able to form so
it's confidence is a very subjective
judgment which is relative to your own
so epilepsy patients have we have tested
this they have very good insight into
their memory strength so it seems like
their ability this is a metacognitive
judge the weak metacognitive judgments
is not impaired so while their memory
strength can be weakened can still
assess that they can still assess it
properly it's not like that capability
is gone if the memory strength is
weakened so they're aware so but their
confidence is high although because they
are of course other diseases from
diseases or executive function is where
the correlation between your ability of
saying hi and the memory actually being
hi is is disrupted but here the way we
do this is we compare the accuracy
that's one of the behavioral slides I
showed ya Chrissie between when you stay
high and low and fee is the accurate
algorithm we actually different and you
can see that by and large this reflects
reality meaning they can do this so that
the second part of your question about
about this being close to or Azure or
before or after seizures that that is
very critical and we make sure that
these these experiments are done at
least four or F or I think even five
hours away from seizures and if somebody
is still in a postictal state which
sometimes can take much longer we
wouldn't we wouldn't do experiments then
so we will and this is assessed by
looking at indirect all discharges to
make sure that brain activity looks
looks looks normal because I think
clearly change the lower extremities
yeah so the question is you know world
focusing on hands and arms have people
looked at legs in terms of the ability
to decode intention from the legs and as
far as I'm aware this has really not
been done with these types of devices in
terms of single unit recordings in
people there's been some work in
non-human primates looking at this but
but really not in people people have
used ACOG style arrays we'll look at
lower limb function maybe in terms of
control but but really the vast majority
of the work cortically in terms of motor
control is focused on arms and hands and
and and much less on legs you know one
of the reasons for that particularly is
that when you think about rehab or
robotic strategies to improve function
there's a lot of interest in hands and
arms locomotion or mobility issues or
maybe reasonably well solved although
you know certainly not completely by
wheelchairs
you know and you know maybe now with
sort of the advances in lower limb
exoskeletons for mobility there would be
increased interest in sort of extracting
control signals from these parts of the
brain one of the challenges is that the
legs are represented in the brain very
basically right along the midline and
are quite deep so actually physical
access with the types of devices that we
use would be much more challenging for
legs than it is for arms and hands
doctor Buffalo humans take about 15
miles to reach criterion while monkeys
take 30 why do you think humans learn
twice as fast as monkeys and what type
of monkeys are using these are good
questions though I neglected to mention
the monkeys that we're using our rhesus
macaque monkeys and we choose them
because they're really well
characterized in terms of anatomy and
physiology they've been used in many
studies and their connectivity
particularly between the medial temporal
lobe in the prefrontal areas that we're
interested in is very similar to human
connectivity and the anatomy of these
structures are also pretty well
conserved so they make a great model for
trying to look at interaction between
these structures in terms of why they
take longer so the test that we that I
talked about the Wisconsin card sorting
task is a pretty complex task and we
were actually thrilled to see that the
monkeys could learn to perform the task
you know at a level that was fairly
close to humans humans still have an
advantage though because we can explain
to them the rules of the game so we can
sort of give them a head start in that
sense and also because humans have the
ability and we think to verbalize
internally verbalize the stimuli that is
they gets you and I think inside you
know that it's gonna be the blue
stimulus and keep thinking of that where
that's not possible for the monkeys we
also think that humans are probably
doing a better job at hypothesis testing
so keeping multiple potential target
features in mind and I've been testing
them systematically through the trials
which will get them spirit
to reach criterion faster we're working
on analysis models that will be able to
allow us to identify kind of the
hypothesis testing that monkeys are
doing
compare that to humans and you are doing
this cross-species work so what do you
find are the most unexpected differences
that you found so far
interesting unexpected differences I
think you know zoom for this task
actually you know we talked about that
the monkeys take longer to reach
criteria for each new rule learning each
new rule but there are other tasks that
we've done where where monkeys actually
outperform the humans and part of this
has to do with I think the training
regime that the monkeys are in that
they're they're highly motivated to kind
of keep going and perform very quickly
on the trials and sometimes that can
lead to actually faster learning and in
the humans so that's been kind of fun to
watch and some of the experiments that
reminds me of those Kyoto working memory
experiments for it a monkey remembers
like 20 characters and their position on
the screen which a human could never do
I think we see similar things you know
not in my lab but in in collaborators
labs were human primates is that you
know the things that primary not even
primates and monkeys are good at and the
things that people are good at are often
just quite different no the real
advantage of working with people which
dr. buffalo mentioned is you can go in
and you can explain the task and 30
seconds later you can be doing
experiments where as you know from Okies
it may take weeks or longer to get that
up but you know in our experience asking
a person to the same task you know over
and over 10,000 times in a row is not a
recipe for success whereas the thing is
possible so that's a great comment thank
you we have a question I believe this is
for dr. richest buzzer in regard to
patience confidence and decision
correlating with retrieval accuracy as I
mentioned people patients who did have
high confidence in their memory actually
were accurate do you then believe if
someone simply had higher confidence and
believed in their memory being good even
if it was not the memory could
potentially improve know in that sense
that would be that would be clearly a
disservice because somebody would
believe that their memory is good when
we need in fact actually is not and that
that clearly can't happen although that
wouldn't be a classical memory disorder
as such but it would be an executive
dysfunction and and some some some
mental disorders clearly would boot
reflect it but I don't believe that
would decrease memory strength as such
and speaking of which we do have a
question on nurse I can reduce disorder
so I'll just pose it to all of you can
you discuss how a deeper understanding
of cognitive control and abilities and
then deficiencies in these functions
could help to help lead to targeted
therapies to treat neuropsychiatric
disorders so I guess how could your work
extend to that we'll start with You dr.
Gondo sure so you know we often don't
associate too many neuropsychiatric
disorders sort of as being it's sort of
exclusively exclusively within these
sensory motor regions and so our work is
more focused on you know on the on these
control issues but I think generally
speaking you know very broadly that the
general idea that if we know we're if we
know the source of the error if we know
what circuits or regions of the brain
are involved in and this then it gives
us through the therapeutic avenues to
explore to treat disease States and
that's certainly been hugely beneficial
in you know there's not a psychiatric is
sort of but you know I you know
Parkinson's disease where there's a
location that we know that this summit
is going on we can then deliver
stimulation to these areas and there
have been you know some some recent some
good work in depression made
pressive disorders and other mood
disorders related to deep brain
stimulation again we're hypothesizing
targets and folk you know places where
things are going wrong can lead to then
sort of the development of therapy for
it yes I'll just add to to what Robert
was saying some of that work on both in
both Parkinson's disease models as well
as for treatment for major depression
depressive disorders really highlights
the importance of this circuit approach
there's some of those work by I think
amplifying or adjusting the connectivity
between different brain regions and
that's something that that we're hoping
with this work is that that we're doing
as part of our u19 is that we can try to
understand again using the circuit
approach what's going on in terms of
memory formation and through testing
both in the non-human primate with
mechanisms for modulation either through
electrical stimulation or
pharmacological mechanisms we can try to
understand how we can affect that
circuit which then may be useful for
future therapies yeah what I mean after
this question is that one of one of the
things that we have focused on in our
grant that that speaks to this question
is is is on the role of different brain
oscillations or something particular
fade oscillations as a mechanism for
cognitive control memory ability so what
what what we are aiming for and what our
hypothesis is that by understanding how
fade oscillations facilitate
coordination between the medial temporal
lobe in our case the medial frontal lobe
during memory retrieval that we then
could design a targeted therapy that
would either restore those fada
oscillations to the way that we
described it or that what that would
would be in fact initiated in a
closed-loop manner at a particular phase
of theta oscillations so that that would
be one way I wish we could facilitate
development of a target targeted error
targeted therapies are so important
because target selection is one of the
hotly debated issues in for example deep
brain stimulation and that is relevant
of course to these changes in synchrony
for different disorders like the beta
oscillations and Parkinson's gamma in
Tourette's etc and so being able to find
these oscillate dysfunctions and use
them as biomarkers and then use that to
be able to really finally localize our
targets not just for example the STM but
what specific area of the STM and how
much of it and when it should be
stimulated so I think that it would it's
wonderful that we're moving in that
direction so we've just gotten started
and unfortunately we're out of time I'd
like to thank all of you dr. gone doctor
root is our du richest Howser and dr.
buffalo for your time and for sharing
your expertise this was really wonderful
and thank you to our audience today for
your thought-provoking questions we can
continue as asking questions of our
speakers and they will be able to follow
up with you via email so thank you again
to our speakers and coming up next
actually speaking of circuit dynamics
please join me as I present on deep
brain stimulation opportunities and
ethical dilemmas hope to see you there
thank you thank you